[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferris welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferris show today we
have a repeat guest and good Lord that
his last episode do well it did
spectacularly well you guys loved it so
back by popular demand is Morgan howel
him on Twitter Morgan housel h l he is a
partner at the collaborative fund his
book the psychology of money which we
really dug into in-depth last time has
sold more than 3 million copies and has
been translated into 53 languages didn't
even know there were that many languages
I'm kidding of course he is a two-time
winner of the best in business award
from the Society of American Business
editors and writers and winner of the
New York Times Sydney award I might be
jealous I might be jealous in
2022 market watch named him one of the
50 most influential people in markets
good friend I have he serves on the
board of directors at marel Morgan's new
book is same as ever subtitle a guide to
what never changes you can find my first
and as I mentioned before widely popular
interview and very tactically dense
interview with Morgan tim. blog Morgan
housel and without further Ado
morgan.com and Morgan himself nice to
see you again nice to see you Tim happy
to be back thanks for having me
absolutely so let's start with a cryptic
prompt and I'll let you run with it
which is Buffett Snickers where should
we go with that so after psychology of
money I was really debating what to
write next for for my next book I'd
thrown around all these different topics
and I I had some good ideas but it
really hadn't hit me what I wanted to
write about and I was at a retreat with
a group of investors about three years
ago and one of the investors he he was
actually a CEO of a large public company
and he's pretty good friends with Warren
and Buffett and he told the story that I
had never heard before about Buffett and
it's it's pretty rare to have a story
about Buffett that I've never heard that
no one's like everybody knows every
Buffett story but this was a new one and
he said the CEO said that in 2009 during
kind of the peak of the Great Recession
when the economy was in pieces he was
driving around Omaha with Warren Buffett
Buffett was driving he was a passenger
and the CEO said to Warren and they're
driving past like closed up shops during
the Great Recession like the like the
whole country is in tatters and the CEO
said Warren how are we ever going to
pull out of this like the country's
never going to be the same after this
and Warren said let's call this guy Jim
that's not his real name but he said Jim
do you know what the bestselling candy
bar was in
1962 and Jim said no and Warren said
Snickers and Warren said do you know
what the best selling candy bar is today
and Jim said no and Warren said Snickers
and that was the end of the conversation
he just stopped right there and that was
his answer to is the country ever going
to be the same and I think if you look
at Warren Buffett's succcess he has been
betting on things that stay the same
forever and it really hit me in that
moment that this was the book that I
wanted to write because for my entire
career as a writer I had been cynical is
probably the right word and just
astounded at how bad people are at
forecasting not just in finance and the
stock market and the economy but in
politics and it's it's been like that
forever like the most famous expert's
ability to predict what's going to
happen next is atrocious and it's always
been atrocious again that that just made
me cynical it was just like the whole
punding industry is a scam that was kind
of my view and then it was like okay is
there a positive spin to this like how
can I use knowing how bad we are at
forecasting to try to like do better at
at my ability to look forward in the
future and I think what I what I settled
on is people are so bad at predicting
the future because they're always trying
to predict what's going to change
they're always trying to predict what's
the next new technology who's going to
win the next election when's the next
recession going to come and our ability
to do that is is zero it's virtually
zero but for the people like Buffett who
focus on what's not going to change
their ability to understand the future
is actually pretty good and so they're
focusing on parts of human behavior that
have never changed that were true 500
years ago that will be true 500 years
from now and so I have no idea when the
next recession is going to come but I
know exactly how people are going to
respond to Greed and fear because that's
never changed there's a great quote from
Naval he says if your life played out a
thousand times a thousand different
iterations of your life what would be
true in 999 of them and those are the
things that you want to focus on in life
because those are not things that are
Guided by luck or chance or you know
just the quirky ways of the world I love
that Framing and it also occurred to me
that a lot of what I had been writing
about for the previous 15 years were
things that never change I think in many
ways psychology of money is the
psychology of you the individual it's
like what's going through your head and
same as ever is the psychology of us as
a collective it's just what do we keep
doing as a society as a group over and
over and over again one other thing that
that really struck me here that was kind
of influential to this book for me was
one of my favorite books is a book
called The Great Depression a diary it's
written by a lawyer named Benjamin Roth
who during the Great Depression kept a
very detailed diary about what he saw
all over his town in Ohio that his son
published and it's like it's the best
economics book ever written and during
that diary there's one diary entry from
I think
1932 where he
says what I see around the Great
Depression 1932 reminds me exactly of
what happened in 1920 and in 1878 and in
1865 and he's like it's the same forces
happening over and over and over again I
thought Ah that's really interesting and
then a couple Pages later it dawned on
me that what he was
writing in 1932 is exactly what happened
in 2008 the way that people were dealing
with uncertainty and greed and fear it
never changes it's the same movie over
and over and over again and so if you
focus on those things that never change
I think it's our only ability to really
understand the future your future
society's future the economy's
future but it's it's just not as
exciting as focusing on what is going to
change like all of the attention in the
media focuses on what's the next big
technology what is gonna change and so
the premise of this book is just like
exactly it's because that's exciting and
it's fun
so the premise of this book is like
let's stop doing that let's focus on
what we know with certainty is going to
be a part of your future and that's the
best that we can do to see the future
I've been excited to have this
conversation for a couple of reasons and
I'll sort of edge into those by way of
maybe a few anecdotes so one I'm not
going to get the attribution right and
I'm not going to get the phrasing
totally on point but there was an
announcement I I think it might have
been Donald n KN n u t but there's a
blog post that I wrote some time ago
which was looking for decisions that
remove a thousand decisions and he made
an announcement when he stopped using
email now I'd be curious to know how
well that's held up Over time however he
said in effect I realize
that I no longer want to stay on top of
things I want to get to the bottom of
things so that phrasing that is really
stuck with me and maybe it we'll come
back to stories and that's his entire
email was maybe a mini story
and had an arc and that has stuck with
me for years now the second is in the
last few weeks I've become very
interested in ancient Sumer and the
dynasties of in Ur and Uruk in modern
day IRA and looking at the birth of
writing as we understand it in CA form
which I never knew was caor instead
of a different pronunciation in any case
the stories as you listen to them in
these various
podcasts if you did a search and replace
with a handful of names this is true for
letters from A stoic or the moral
letters to lucilius as well from senica
the younger if you just did a search
repl with some names it's the same set
of Dynamics it's the same foibles of
human nature it's the same consequences
of fear greed wrath Fillin the blank and
my question for you is given how much
you've thought about writing given how
much you have written I mean you've
written I would imagine hundreds
thousands of pieces and we spoke quite a
bit about writing in our last
conversation
and the fact that writing is on some
level or good writing at least the type
of writing that we do is sort of
intrinsically selfish right we're
writing for at least an audience of one
and that I'm just going to do a quick
recap on some of the things that stuck
with me from our last conversation which
have proven to be true again and again
and again for instance and please fact
check me but good writing is easy bad
writing is hard right if you're just
like struggling through word by word
this slog of a piece chances are it's
just not going to be good and also if
you have writer block there's a damn
good chance it's just a shitty idea or a
mediocre idea that you're trying to
force into some existence of all the
things that you could write about how
did you choose to do this especially
after the success of your last book I
was told many years ago by Jason zag a
great friend and mentor mind from The
Wall Street Journal that you should only
write a book if in your brain you have
to do it not like oh I should do it or
like oh that's a lot of money that I
could get for doing it only doing it if
you're like I can't sleep until I get
these ideas on paper and even in blog
form for my entire career that's always
been the case I'm not a you know sit
down at my desk at nine o'clock and
publish by four o'clock kind of person
I've always been I'm just going to toss
around a bunch of ideas in my head and
I'm only going to sit down and write
when I I can't do anything else until I
get this done the idea is so fresh and
it's just spilling out of me and there's
been plenty of times when we'll be like
grocery shopping with my wife and kids
and I'm basically just like I I have to
go I need to go sit down at the computer
and write this out and the opposite of
that if I'm like oh I should probably
write something this week let's Force
out the words it's garbage every single
time and so I feel like I didn't
necessarily choose to write this book I
think I would have been really happy
just stop just stopping at psychology of
money and saying that's great I'm just
going to quit while I'm ah head which is
a general idea that I really admire
but I think it got to the point where I
was like I really I have to do this and
it struck me around it was kind of the
early days of Co when this really struck
me I was writing almost every week
almost every day about things that never
change and putting a lot of thought into
it and it really became like a
philosophy that guides my entire life
and I think to to tell you the truth it
relieved a lot of anxiety from my life
once I kind of internalized a lot of
these ideas anxiety about the future
what's my future hold what's the economy
going to do next during the early days
of Co what's Co going to do next Once
you admit that we have no idea we have
no clue we have no clue what going to
happen but that doesn't mean that you're
giving up or just becoming a fatalist
it's just like let's shift our attention
to what we know is going to be true and
I I I honestly think I became happier
and calmer and like my life improved
once I got to that point so in a sense
is
that a Serenity
Prayer applied to your life through the
lens of human nature over time I mean in
a sense I mean separating the things
that you can change from the things that
you cannot the things that you can
predict with some certainty versus the
many things that you cannot is that what
reduced the anxiety I think so and of
course this is not an idea I came up
with that's kind of the core of stoicism
it's been around for 2,000 years it's
like what can you control and what can
you not just you really need to be able
to figure out how to to separate those
so I'm not claiming at all that I came
up with these ideas but once it became
wait a created Buddhism and sto
exactly good for in 2020 it was amazing
it was a very productive
year but once I kind of crystallize them
and and I could contextualize that in a
way that made a lot of sense to me I
honestly think it improved my life in in
a pretty profound way so we're going to
come back to that we're going to come
back to it quickly but since I am
getting back into writing and I've been
experimenting with fiction largely but
I'd like to
actually write some non-fiction blog
posts in the in the old
style back when there were blog rolls I
want to really rewind the clock and go
retro with some of my writing because I
do have some ideas that that are are so
persistent that I feel like it would be
beneficial for me to write in order to
think about them more clearly and what
we didn't cover in our last conversation
was how you draft your first drafts or
your rough drafts because you have these
ideas you're at the grocery store you're
out on a walk you're in the shower
whatever it might
be what does it look like when you put
first words on paper or screen because
that is where I often procrastinate
facing the empty screen the blinking
cursor what's your move there I first
need to disclose that what I'm about to
say is probably the worst writing advice
you could give someone so if you are a
new writer or an aspiring writer like
plug your ears and fast forward this
I've always been including wor advice
for writers always been like this and I
I don't think it's it's a good strategy
but it's been my
strategy I'm kind of a first draft and
published writer I think the best way to
write is to write a shitty first draft
get it done and then go back and edit
and clean up and rewrite and whatnot
I've always been one sentence at a time
and when I'm done with that sentence
it's final so by the time I get to the
bottom of the article or the bottom of a
of a chapter it's pretty much done but
that's not because I can write a perfect
first draft it's because I'm not going
to leave
this sentence that I'm writing until
it's perfect I'm not going to move on to
the next sentence until every word is
perfect that's always how I've been I
believe Kurt vonet talked about swoopers
and plotters I may be getting the the
wording wrong but swoopers are the vomit
of first draft refine refine into a
diamond and then the
plotters are the line at a time one
small facet at a time and then they're
kind of done I tend to ER on the side of
being closer to that myself
however that doesn't seem to work unless
you have a clear idea of what your
structure is going to look like or at
least of where you're going to
start so that you're not then endlessly
swapping things around or scrapping the
first half in which case you're edging
more towards that refine refine refine
so how do you figure out the structure
of a piece or what your lead is going to
be when I start an article or a chapter
even I have no idea where it's going to
go it's not like all the ideas are in my
head and I just need to put them out on
paper and I feel like the process of
writing is the research process for me
and so that's kind of where the plotter
style comes in which is I write one
sentence and I sit there and stare at it
and it's like oh that reminds me of this
oh like that prompts another thought
that I had this that paragraph I just
wrote reminds me of something else I can
pull in that's that's really where it
comes from so coming up with a with an
idea honestly I think most blog posts I
start with a headline and I'm like I
want to write an article called
Everything Is psychical whatever it
might be and let's just run with that
like that idea like because everything
is psychical and I'm sure I could put
together a story about why that is and a
couple examples of that so let's just
start there and see what happens and I
just start throwing things on on the
page and usually within the process of a
blog post or a book chapter I'll go for
three walks around my neighborhood and
during that walk I'm 100% focused on
what I'm writing and thinking about what
did I just write is that is that true oh
actually that reminds me of something
else
so that's always a process if I'm
sitting at my desk I really can't get my
brain to work as well as it is is what
I'm getting up and walking around so
very often too if the weather's bad
outside in the middle of writing I'll
like get up and fold the laundry or get
up and do the dishes get up and just
walk around the house it's just like I
think movement is really critical to
forming new thoughts and moving the
piece along which is so critical when
you don't know where it's going to go
when you started writing it mhm so let's
look at a post of yours and I read three
in prepping for this conversation
respect and admiration rich and
Anonymous and then expectation de how
did you decide to write rich and
Anonymous and maybe that's a way
to move
into discussing some of the content some
of the some of the messages some of the
stories in that piece but how did that
come to be rich and Anonymous came to be
because this was probably about two
years ago I did a Consulting session
with a group of NBA athletes most of
them were NBA rookies and the topic of
conversation was everybody knows that
NBA athletes all pro athletes have a
very high rate of going bankrupt they
have a three to five year career where
they make tens of millions of dollars
they blow it all and then they're done
everyone knows the story so the top of
conversation is like how do we prevent
that and one of the athletes who's 19
from the NBA he had he had very recently
been drafted to a decillion dollar
contract massive amount of money he
brought up this fact that I thought was
so astute particularly for a 19-year-old
and he said when you grow up in inner
city poverty and then you you make tens
of millions of dollars at age 19 that's
not your money that is Mom's money dad's
money cousins money brother's money
neighbors money Grandma's money you
can't just tell all of them I got my
money like good luck to you all back in
inner city poverty it doesn't work like
that and he said the biggest reason that
athletes go bankrupt is not because they
bought themselves a mansion it's because
they bought their fifth cousin a modest
house and they felt so much obligation
to help them so that was this idea that
I came up I don't know if I came up with
it but I I called it social debt and I
think with every dollar that you earn
comes some amount of social debt and for
somebody like an athlete or a movie star
there's a ton of social for every dollar
that they earn there's probably four
dollars of social debt that comes on top
of it and it's very easy to track your
net worth it's incredibly difficult to
track your social debt it's this obscure
figure but it's always there and even if
we're not talking about athlet you know
decillion dollar athletes I think for
the average person who gets a raise you
know their salary goes from 50,000 to
55,000 with that even comes an increase
in expectations of now they expect to
live in a bigger apartment to wear nicer
clothes to eat out more and just their
expectation increase that comes with
that is a form of social debt that came
with it and so that is this idea I'm
pretty sure that nval came up with this
phrasing too that the best spot you want
to be in in life is Rich and Anonymous
the worst is poor and famous
which was maybe like Monica Lewinsky or
something like very famous and no money
that's the worst position you can be in
Richard Anonymous is the best I spent
some time with a family two or three
years ago the family is worth eight
billion doll and if you Google their
name nothing comes up they are
completely Anonymous they're not on any
Forbes list they've not done any
interviews they donate their money
anonymously and that's all very
intentional and so this family has is
worth $8 billion and they have virtually
no social debt like can just walk down
the street they can go to any cheap
restaurant nobody knows who they are and
they've been very cognizant of doing
that and I when I see how happy they are
and how well balanced they are how well
balanced their children were it was like
that's the spot that everyone wants to
be in so even if you're not a worth
eight billion dollars like that
realizing that every dollar of net worth
that you gain comes with probably at
least a couple pennies of social debt I
think is a really important thing to
think about and contemplate so let me
ask you more about this family all right
8 billion that's non-trivial so you
would think that this family would be on
many Radars many lists whether they want
to appear there or not and I think it's
probably sector dependent I don't want
you to share anything you don't want to
share but there may be some sectors
there are more sectors that are prone to
being publicly exposed or of public
interest than others right if you're a
defense contractor maybe the people who
read People magazine are not as
interested as if you are a movie star or
fill in the blank right but what are
some of the decisions outside of
anonymous
donations that you think were critical
for them or might have been part of this
plan and then I have I have some other
questions related to their kids and the
happiness of their kids because last
time we spoke about I'm blanking on the
name of the book but the I think it was
the Vanderbilt yep fortune and how
almost uniformly miserable everyone was
Downstream of the inflation adjusted
whatever crazy number it was $400
billion do or something like that yeah
so coming back to the the question that
I I led with what were some of the the
decisions or types of decisions they
made that contributed to that outcome
what's so interesting about this family
and of course I'm not going to give any
details to disclose who they were but
they made their money in a very ethical
way it's not like they're trying to hide
the fact that of how they made their
money and what's also interesting is
that if I told you the name of the
company you would know it it's not this
hidden obscure business you would know
what it is but they've again they've
been very intentional about doing
everything anonymously not being part of
any fundraiser Gayla not you living
actually they live a fairly good life I
would hope
so but it was based around this idea of
how do we not ruin our children I think
that was really it how do we raise
children who are well balanced and
understand the world world and are not
treated differently than anyone else
back to the Vanderbilts which is such a
crazy story there is this anecdote in
one of the books where one of the
Vanderbilt grandchildren wants to learn
how to play soccer so they gather up all
the servants in the mansion that they
live in and they're like go play soccer
with our kid and they're watching it and
the servants who are I have to imagine
where this is going the servants are all
just getting their ass kicked by this
8-year-old they let every goal go
through no one is going to try to take
the ball from him I knew it you know and
of course the eight-year-old is like I'm
so good I'm so good at soccer so as soon
as people know who you are and what your
last name is how much they treat you
differently and that's not good that is
a terrible thing laugh at all your dumb
jokes exactly dorse all your dumb ideas
I don't think I've ever talked about
this before but I've told my wife this
in my tenure at the collaborative fund
there was a period early on when I was
doing deals and I was meeting with
entrepreneurs entrepreneurs who were
trying to raise money from the
collaborative fund and it was astounding
that when I was talking to an
entrepreneur who wanted to raise money
every joke that I said was so funny
every Insight that I had was so wise
when people want something from you they
treat you differently and and it's not
good so this back to the family that
that I did some work with they wanted to
move mountains to avoid that they wanted
their children to be treated normally
and I have so much respect and
admiration for that and going into this
a lot of what I was going to do was talk
to the children about about money that
was kind of my my role in this
experience
and if I'm honest going into it I
expected them all to be spoiled little
brats and they were the opposite they
were the most well-balanced polite
well-mannered kids and what they had
that I thought was so great is a sense
of like anxiety about who they are in
the world and that's really rare for a
child who grows up with that kind of
means most of them are just kind of it's
in their identity that I'm special I'm
the best I'm the richest I'm the
smartest that's their tends to be their
identity and these children were
completely normal if you didn't know
their net worth and you met them you
would think that they were the children
of like plumbers and accountants if I
could pause for one second and I want to
get into some specifics maybe what you
took away from that or some of the
things that they did if if you're able
to share to produce that outcome now
maybe just out of the box this family is
programmed a little differently so we're
looking at maybe I don't want to say a
reversed causality but we might be
looking
at something that existed out of the box
so to speak psychologically however
there probably some levers that people
can pull and this doesn't just apply to
families with 8 billion for instance I
grew up without very much money and in
my neighborhood on Long Island you know
the family that made 75k versus the
families that made 40K had a similar
psychological Dynamic right the kids had
better toys they had bigger TV and that
came with it unchecked a
certain arrogance even even though they
were by no stretch close to a family
with $8 billion the sort of positional
economics of it
were something
similar
and as I think more about kids myself I
think about this a lot because you don't
need to be in the stratosphere
economically to for this to be a
relevant topic right to think about and
if you're born in the US with your
native language as English in a
reasonably safe place like you've
already won a lot of lotteries right so
from a Global Perspective you can also
subconsciously develop some pretty kind
of perverse orientations toward the
world so what what are some things that
they did or that people can do to
produce kids or bend the arc a little
bit towards kids who are less entitled
and more self-aware in the way that
you're describing I've thought about
this a lot and it's a question I get a
lot I'm sure how do you raise kids that
don't grow up to be spoiled little brats
and I've come to the conclusion that the
only answer is give them less money
that's it yeah it's the answer that
nobody wants to hear yeah but I don't I
don't think there's any other way around
it the reason that money is valuable is
because you usually have to work hard
for it if you don't have to work hard
for it it becomes not that valuable to
you I see so give them less money not
just in the sense of inheritance but
you're saying on an ongoing basis like
allowance toys yes Etc totally of course
like everyone I just kind of anchor to
my old childhood when thinking about
this my parents particularly later in my
childhood they had some means and I got
very little from it and at the time that
sucked I looked back on it and think
that was great that was so good because
from age 16 I learned how to be
self-dependent and I learned how to work
and I learned how to do it and there's
there's a good friend of mine named
Chris Davis who his grandfather Shelby
Davis is one of the Mount Rushmore
investors he became a billionaire in the
1980s just from picking stocks and Chris
Davis and his cousins and siblings got
nothing did not get one single scent
from it and his grandfather Shelby Davis
would tell them I'm not going to rob you
of the opportunity of earning your own
income and that was that's the right way
to view it and I think every scent that
you give your children particularly your
older children you are robbing them of
that opportunity my wife and I think a
lot about that with our own kids of
every cell in your body as a parent
wants to say I want to provide for my
kids support my kids boost my kids give
them all the benefit and it's so hard to
push back against that natural mentality
and say no I'm going to I'm going to
make you do it on your own I'll give you
one perfect example here I grew up ski
racing M my son who's now seven I
started taking him skiing about two
years ago and because I'm a a fairly
Advanced skier it was no problem for me
on the first day to hold him between my
legs and ski down there no problem for
me to do that and so that's what I did
and I I thought it was the right thing
to do hey I'm gonna make this easy for
you I'll just hold you between my legs
and we'll ski down together and my son
is very physically coordinated very
physically talented but because I did
that it took him about 10s s of going
skiing before he could do it on his own
because I babed him what I should have
done is strapped him in and kicked him
down the slope said go for it learn
yourself learn how to fall and if I did
that he would have gotten it in two runs
instead it took him 10 sessions to do it
and I think there it's a great analogy
for what money can do to your children
too it's so hard to do but when you see
examples of it I think every parent
listening will understand this like
sometimes you just got to click them
into their skis and kick them down I'm
going to hijack this for my own selfish
purposes for a second
I find it very frustrating I have found
it very frustrating over the last say
five
to 10 years when speaking to very ultra
high net worth people from a
philanthropic standpoint if I'm
fundraising for something that is
clearly High leverage clearly Capital
efficient with good operators but in the
nonprofit space how many demure or push
back with some argument along the lines
of and they wouldn't word it this way
but compounding more into dynastic
wealth I'll do more good later often the
subtext of that is they want to give
this dynastic wealth to their kids they
will not say that explicitly but there's
a there's a protecting of the nest egg
so to speak in their response and what
I'm curious to hear from you because
you've spent a lot of time around very
very very wealthy people if you had a
billion dollars of net worth and how
many kids do you have two two all right
how much would you give to your kids
versus versus give away before you die
versus something else what would you do
with that such a good question and of
course we don't have a billion dollars
so this is all it's it's great that this
is purely hypothetical I mean it might
be greater if you had a billion dollars
I don't know but yeah it's hypothetical
so it's easy to talk about yeah and this
is is what we plan to do now of course
our kids would get the best education
they would always have healthare no
matter what decisions they make in life
we'd probably you know pay for a a great
wedding and some great family vacations
if we were billionaires we might say
we'll buy you a house and that's pretty
much it I think that's that's pretty
much it I I love the idea from the book
die with zero that if you're I was just
gonna mention it it's such a good book
It's a Wonderful book everyone should
read and a lot of the premises is if
you're gonna give your kids money don't
wait until you die at age 97 to do it
give your kids money when they need it
in their 30s and 40s
and so my wife and I think our our kids
are four and seven but I think about
that now and thankfully my my kids won't
listen to this episode uh for for many
more years hopefully part of my
exploding seven-year-old
demographic stardom Young on the Tim
Ferris show exactly we don't plan to
leave them much of any death inheritance
but to the extent that we're going to
give them a very small amount of money
we're probably going to give it to them
in their 30s and 40s when they need it
the most so let's continue with this
hypothetical thought exercise
okay so you don't give them an excess
let's just say you add up all of those
things and while you're alive you know
God willing you give your kids who knows
inflation adjusted you have a billion
dollars just to keep it simple right
let's assume that's all reasonably
liquid each of them gets two million
bucks before you kick the bucket people
have not figured out you know vampire
transfusions with 20-year-olds from
Lithuania or whatever all the tech
billionaires are trying these days
whatever the latest and greatest is
hasn't really out right so you Arc and
then you come to a natural end that
still leaves a lot left over would you
again as a thought exercise would you
donate most of that over the course of
your lifespan what would be the plan for
the
leftover $998
million I'm really ashamed of this this
is not a good thing but it's only been
in the last two years that my wife and I
have really thought about giving money
away and we just started doing it in a
very modest amount and for people who
have done it I think you'll agree with
this it's actually a lot harder than
you'd think it's actually very very
difficult to give it away in a way that
you feel like is making a big difference
and you feel great about and is going to
the right causes it it should be easier
than and it's not it's actually very
difficult I've always been most
interested in microf philanthropy what I
call it like rather than donate to a big
charity I want to find like a single
mother who's struggling and give money
directly to her that sort of thing and
that's actually I think the the hardest
form of Charity to do I'll tell you two
examples of this that that I've had that
were really profound for me one was I
was in New York City and I walked past I
think it was a a CVS and there was a
mother and a child who looked like my
son and who were saying can we please
have some money for food and because the
child looked like my son it was like I
have to stop so I I went to the mother
and I said grab a shopping cart and fill
it up and you can get anything you want
which by the way my mother did I saw my
mother do this to someone when I was a
child say grab a shopping cart and
filled up no limits so we did this she
went into CVS I kind of followed them
around and I said no just fill the card
up and when they were done with it I
paid and they just walked out not a
thank you not a look in the eye nothing
let me make clear I was not doing this
because I wanted the attention or
because I wanted the thank you but I
wanted some indication that I made a
difference I wanted some information
that it helped and I didn't get it and
that's what made it really hard and in
my heart I'm like I know this made a
difference I know that kid can eat and
then that that's why I did it but in
anything you do in life you want
feedback that what you're doing is
working and in a lot of these situations
you don't get it and of course people
who are begging for food for their child
probably don't have the emotional
capacity to say thank it's not what's
going through their head I completely
understand it but that's what makes it
so difficult and I've had that that
similar situation happen many times to
do it so when I think about if giving
away $200 is very difficult how do you
give away 998 million or if you're Bill
Gates and Warren Buffett how do you give
away 200
billion very very difficult to do
extremely difficult to do I mean I think
the best analogy for this is really what
the federal government is is a giant
charity program uh with the exception of
like defense and whatnot that's kind of
what it is and it's not very well-run
like most people don't like how it's run
because it's so difficult to do and make
everybody happy yeah yeah totally I mean
if your options are somebody put it to
me because you know I've been asking a
lot of people this question because to
to emphasize again this might seem like
rarified error and people are like come
on why are we talking about a billion
dollars number one because it's sort of
a large absurd amount of money and
unwieldy for the reasons that you just
described although I think a lot of
people who are in that upper echelon let
perfect be the enemy of good right they
want to like do more homework and do
more diligence and they could do a lot
of good sooner on compounding problems
but they put it off because they're
hoping for perfect information that will
let them pick like the winning stocks of
all the nonprofits which I think is very
challenging to do and often just a means
of postponing things but they said look
your options
are taxes to the US government your kids
or charity yes which would you prefer
and like you said I mean look I I pay
taxes like everybody else but it's it's
not always the best run so would you
prefer it to go there would you prefer
it to go to a nonprofit or a set of
nonprofits if you're choosing but let's
zoom out because I want this to apply
obviously to more people mentioned the
stoic a little bit earlier senica the
younger who's a very controversial
figure for a lot of good reasons but
he's a hell of a quote machine he's like
the Arnold Schwarzenegger oneliner of
the stoics but he said you know people
talk of having riches when often riches
have them I much like a fever right and
this is paraphrasing but of course we're
all paraphrasing it's translated it
wasn't published in English but how
would you suggest people think about
money or income and happiness this has
come up on the podcast quite a lot but
this is something that comes up in human
history even more often what are some
patterns or takeaways or lessons learned
from your observation and study of these
things one thing that I think is is
really true and it's coming out a lot
more in the data is that if you are
already happy gaining more money will
probably make you happier but if you're
already kind of depressed gaining more
money is probably not going to help that
much there's a really interesting
documentary about J Paul Getty who uh
used to be the richest man in the world
and and I think that the interview is
taking place in the 1960s or 1970s in
his castle in England and it is a
Bonafide castle like straight out of a
fiction book and he's sitting there in
this like 700 foot long dining room
surrounded by gold and diamonds like the
most ostentatious thing you can see and
the interviewer says who are you envious
of and the interviewer says like
obviously everyone's envious of you who
are you envious of and the guy he's so
morose he's so glum and he just kind of
looks down and he says people who are
happier than me and it was like that's
the case money didn't money didn't help
him because he was already depressed and
in that situation it's it's not going to
do much but I think if you are the kind
of person who already has a chaper
disposition you're already happy then
ging more money will probably improve
your life that I think is kind of an
unfortunate iron just like because so
many people who are depressed will think
to themselves if only I had money it
would fix everything and it it's
probably not the case there's a really
great quote in Will Smith's biography
where he says when Will Smith was poor
and depressed he could say to himself if
only I had more money everything would
be better and then when he was rich and
depressed he he didn't have that hope
anymore he like money actually
subtracted The Hope from his life
because he realized there's nothing else
to strive for so I think that's the case
if you're already depressed that's who
you're going to be when you're rich and
this is just highlighting something that
a million people have said and everyone
already knows is that money just
accentuates who you are if you're a jerk
it's going to make you more of a jerk if
you're happy it's probably going to make
you happier it's like power or alcohol
or many drugs it's an amplifier exactly
one of the things that's really
interesting to me the new biography of
Elon Musk Walter Isaacson is
interviewing musk's first wife whose
name is Justine and she met Elon in
college before he was any successful he
was just an immigrant from South Africa
he didn't have any money no success
that's when she met him and she talks
about how much money and fame changed
him it just completely altered his
personality the other thing that I've
always found interesting is that if you
go back and look at an interview of
Donald Trump in the early 1980s there
are several of them you can find on
YouTube when he was known but not famous
and he was probably wealthy but not
rich you would not recognize him utterly
different person very calm very measured
very reasonable and even if you are a
huge Trump fan I think you would be
stunned at who the person is on camera
so any of us me you anyone if we became
into that level of Fame and power and
money it would change us and there
there's another quote from J Paul Getty
where he says nobody would be the same
if they could afford to be different and
I think that's a sad quote but I think
there's a lot do that he says nobody
would be the same if they could afford
to be
different what do you think he meant by
that I think he was probably mentioning
in the sense of does money make you
happier does money change who you are
and I think all of us want to imagine
that if you and I stumbled across a
billion dollars tomorrow we would be the
same people we would have the same
friends the same interests the same
Hobbies the same disposition the same
personality and I think there's enough
examples of this where the answer is we
would not yeah there are probably some
exceptions that we could think of but I
think every single person who comes into
that kind of money is a different person
becomes a different person I wonder if
they become a different person or if
it's similar to the quote I wish I could
recall the attribution but adversity
doesn't build character it reveals it I
wonder if it's it's kind of like
watching someone with money interact
with a waiter or a waitress who's having
a tough first day or a busy section when
people don't need to be nice anymore how
do they behave yes I think that's
exactly it whereas when you're still in
building mode on some level especially
if you're socially aware you're playing
I shouldn't say all people most people
are going to play the game consciously
or subconsciously be on better Behavior
but when you really have [__] you money
right how often you actually say [__]
you right I think that's maybe a measure
of what was a kernel of the personality
or the hidden personality the better
hidden personality
beforehand also I don't want to end on
basically if you think your life sucks
now doesn't matter what money you make
you're probably going to still think
your life sucks because it's pretty now
even if it's true it's sort of a sour
note to end this chapter of the
conversation on so I want to explore it
a little bit further but what were you
going to say well I was going to say I
was in Omaha Nebraska last week
obviously Warren Buffett's Hometown and
I was driving along the freeway and
there's a giant building one of the
tallest buildings in town that on top of
the building in enormous probably 50
foot letters says Buffett Cancer
Research Center so he's funded it he's
bought it Warren drives past that
building every day and sees that and
there's no way that seeing your name on
something like that there's no way that
he's the same Warren Buffett who drove
past that building when he was 13 yeah
it's going to completely change just
your view of who you are in the world to
your point about let's not leave this on
a sad note because you're right it's I I
I I do think money can be used to give
yourself a better life what the
distinction we need to make is the
distinction between happiness and
contentment does money bu happiness I
think that answer is pretty firmly no
can money by contentment I think that's
a pretty firm yes and that's great
contentment is a great trait that makes
your life better but it's very different
from happiness could you just Define
that term so we understand what we're
talking about I would say happiness is
you wake up grinning ear to ear
happiness is you're out at a bar with
your friends happiness is you hear the
funniest joke you've ever heard and
that's what I think people strive for
and they think that money is going to
give to them and it won't but I think
contentment is you just wake up with a
low or virtually no level of anxiety
you're like I'm good I'm pretty
satisfied with my career I'm satisfied
with my relationships I'm satisfied with
the house that I live in that's not
happiness though so I think money can
reduce the number of sad days that you
have but it's probably not going to
increase the number of happy days that
you have now that's awesome like if you
can do that that's a huge life
Improvement but it's not happiness yeah
unless you have standup comedy budget
and you go to more standup comedy shows
which that's actually a great point I'm
not really kidding that's something that
I do quite a lot
of I've been on such a a comedy binge
lately just on Netflix specials I've
said this many times but I think
comedians are the only good thought
leaders yeah they're the only practical
philosophers left exactly and not only
do you laugh but you get smarter I think
think George Carlin was a Bonafide
genius I think Bill Burr is a genius
those guys understand human behavior
better than any psychology PhD does so
let's take a hard left from what we're
talking about let's talk about
avalanches I'll let you take the Baton
and go from there avalan just scare the
living hell out of me I do have a decent
amount I no no expert skier to the
extent that you used to compete and so
on but I have done in the last handful
of years there's quite a lot of side
country and Backcountry skiing
and this just scares the wits out of me
yeah does not get less scary with each
passing year so tell me about
your your experience with
Avalanches I grew up as a competitive
ski racer in in Lake Tahoe and you know
most of those big years were when I was
a teenager 16 17 18 and my friends and I
there were about a dozen of us on the
squad Valley ski team and we spent we we
skied six days a week 10 months Year
we're always we skied all over the world
always traveling around and one day this
is February of 2001 I was 17 years old
at the time and Lake Tahoe where we
lived had just been dumped on just got
an absolute monster blanket of snow
dumped on and the layering of snow was
very important to the story so at one
point squa got about two feet of very
light fluffy snow and then after that it
got about two feet of very wet heavy
snow on top of that which we didn't
think about this at the time but that
creates a textbook perfect Avalanche
condition because you have heavy snow on
top of light snow it slides very easily
so one day in February 2001 myself and
two of my friends Brendan Allen and
Brian Richmond were skiing and we would
ski Out of Bounds at Squad Valley we
would duck under the ropes that say do
not cross to ski the untouched untracked
parts of the mountain that are so much
fun to do and when you when you do that
there's no chairlift at the bottom we
would ski to the bottom and then
hitchhike back once we got spit out on a
back Country Road the three of us did
this run on the back side of squa we had
done it maybe a half dozen times before
not that often because it's such a pain
in the ass to hitchhike but we ski down
like it was so great it was so awesome
and halfway down we triggered a small
Avalanche and it was pretty small it
like came up to our knees and it's it's
the most bizarre feeling because you
very suddenly have no control at all
because rather than pushing on the snow
to gain traction the snow's pushing you
so all of a sudden you go from skiing to
I'm on a roller coaster is how it feels
but it ended pretty quickly and we got
to the bottom and I I remember saying to
Brendon I remember saying like holy [__]
did you see that Avalanche it was so we
laughed about it and we hitch like back
and didn't say another word about it we
get back down to squa and brenon and
Brian say hey let's do it again and I I
have no idea why but I said I'm I I I
don't want to do it again I think
hitchhiking kind of freaked me out but
Bren and Brian said okay we're gonna do
it again and I said hey rather than
hitchhiking I'll drive my car around and
pick you guys up so you don't have to
hitchhike so we went our separate ways
Bren and Brian went and did the run
again I I went down took my boots off
drove around to pick them up and when I
got to the spot where we were going to
pick them up they were not there and I I
didn't think that much about it I
thought maybe they had already hitch
like back I think I was late so I was
like oh that like I felt bad that I was
late picking them up and they had
already left and I drove back to our
locker room and they weren't there
either and no one no one had seen them
and this was before cell phones but like
prior to cell phones people were very
comfortable being out of touch unlike
they are today if you didn't know where
someone was I was like yeah whatever
they're somewhere else so we didn't
think anything of it and later that day
Brian's mom called me and she said hey
Brian didn't show up for work today and
she had also just spoken to Brendan's
dad and Brendan missed a dentist
appointment that afternoon and she said
do you know do you know where they are
and I said yeah we skied the backside of
squa which we was was we were not
supposed to do was out of bounds and I
was going to pick them up but they never
showed up and no one SE them since and
Brian's mom who's an expert skier said
oh my God and she clicked the the phone
she hung up and I think in that moment
both both of us figured out what
happened without saying it both of us
knew what happened and the day went on
we we called the police we got a missing
person's report the police didn't take
it seriously at all but eventually that
evening we got search and rescue
involved and they went out it was still
a blizzard they had a team of search
dogs and these giant flood lights to
search for them and the next morning
about 9:00 a.m. the next morning the
search dogs had honed in on a spot in
the Avalanche field and Rescuers with
these giant probe poles to probe the
snow found Brandon and Brian buried
about six feet down from a massive
Avalanche they The Rescuers had just
said it looked like half the mountain
had been torn away and they were they
were dead of course and so that you know
I was 17 that had like a huge profound
impact on my life this is not that
unique of a story everyone has lost
somebody close to them everyone's had a
near-death experience themselves but
this was my version of that and it
shredded me completely tore me to pieces
and it wasn't until years later that I
had pieced together a couple of
takeaways from this that impacted my
life personally one was my decision to
not go on the second run with them was
completely Thoughtless and brainless I
didn't weigh the pros and cons I didn't
say oh no it's too dangerous I didn't
say I didn't think anything of it I
think I was probably just tired and I
said you guys go do another run and I
won't if I had went with them I would
have 100% chance I would have died so
the most important decision that I ever
made in my life it was not where to go
to college it was not whom to marry the
most important decision I ever made on
my life was to not go on the second run
with them and I put no thought into it
it was a complete random fluke and so
like one of the takeaways there for me
was just like how fragile life is
there's this great quote from Tim Urban
who I think is probably been on your
show before where he says if you had a
time machine and you can go back in time
you would be terrified because you would
realize that the tiniest little no
nothing decision that you make can
flourish into completely change your
life in good ways and bads like most
people how they met their spouse was a
complete random fluke that ended up
really important to them and so you
realize just how incredibly fragile life
is and how there might be a decision
that you make today that I make today
that we think nothing about the random
decision that goes on to change
everything so that that story that
experience had a profound impact on me
I'm thinking about risk thinking about
the tail end consequences of like of
risk thinking about how fragile the
world is it just it went on to impact
virtually everything in my life
from that one
day well number one I mean I'm so sorry
obviously for the loss of your friends
and the the story for all the reasons
you described is terrifying not just
from the Avalanche perspective but from
the angle of looking at how small
decisions can have huge impacts and also
how I think as we discussed in the last
conversation you know risk is what's
left when you've thought of everything
else now in this particular case I
suppose if you'd really taken a moment
to sit down with the pro and cons you
probably would have figured out that it
was a bad idea but in the moment you
could have very easily made the wrong
decision I suppose part of what I'm
wondering because you've become very
good at
interrogating the world and your own
Thoughts with questions right in that in
that particular moment you made a snap
judgment it's not really a snap judgment
you made a snap decision that saved your
life but you have questions that you
seem to explore or revisit with some
regularity some of them we discussed in
the last interview but I'm going to I'm
just going to read a few so what are we
ignoring today that will seem shockingly
obvious in a year which of our current
views would change if our incentives
were
different and it goes on and on I mean
there there are many others I mean
there's one that I had not heard before
which is what hassle are you trying to
eliminate that's actually an unavoidable
cost of success that's pretty
interesting to me who has the right
answers but we ignore because they're
not articulate what looks unsustainable
that is actually a new trend we haven't
accepted yet so my my macro question
about these questions is how you arrived
at these questions whether it was coming
up with them or borrowing them or
adapting them
and which of these might be worth
exploring as uh our next chapter in this
conversation I think maybe the core of a
lot of these questions is that everybody
including myself thinks that their
experience in life is roughly how the
world Works without realizing that their
experience in life is so very unique to
their life and so you and I are white
American males and I think it's common
for us naturally to think that the
experiences that you and I have had and
how people treat us is how everyone else
is treated of course that's not true
yeah and so I think when you accept that
the world that I've experienced is so
different from the world that you've
experienced and other people then I
think you just start asking these
questions about like what else is out
there that I haven't seen that I'm
oblivious to and the fact is that I and
you and everyone is oblivious to 99.99%
of the world completely oblivious to how
it works because we're centered on on
what we've experienced so that's where a
lot of it comes I think a lot of it too
and this is an unhealthy mindset but I
spend 99% of my life thinking about the
past and contemplating the future the
worst thing that you can do like
virtually never present so I I think I'm
constantly interrogating the past of
like what could it have been why did
that happen what would my life have been
like if that happened my parents were
visiting us uh just last week and my
mother was and is at a very high risk of
breast cancer by age 42 she was the
oldest surviving female in her family
her sister her mother her grandmother
everyone had died of breast cancer and
and my mother is now 70 and she's
healthy fingers crossed knock on wood
but we were talking the other day about
when we were growing up and myself and
my siblings were children that my father
and mother would would cry if if my
mother had a lump that needed to get
checked out they would hold each other
and cry cry this is going to be the one
and it's so Bonkers for me to
contemplate if my childhood had had
ended up differently and it so easily
could not only could it have it probably
should have like statistically she
should have died of breast cancer 30
years ago and the fact that it didn't so
I I actually spent this is probably
unhealthy but I spent a lot of my time
contemplating What would life have been
like if my mother died when I was 10
years old I I actually I'll take that
back I think that is a pretty healthy
thing to think about to imagine a life
that's different than it could have been
because I think It prepares you for a
more variant future than You're
Expecting but and the truth is that
nothing would have been the same I would
have gone to different schools I would
have had different friends I would have
had a different mindset I would had a
different career if that had happened
and you can say that for a billion
different things in life and then you
realize that the path that got you to
where you are
today was completely unforeseeable and
completely random and in many ways
outside of your control everyone I think
particularly successful people want to
think that their success was entirely if
not overwhelmingly due to the decisions
that they made
and I think and virtually any condition
and any example that's not the case it's
also a very fragile framework right
because you're then either excellent or
terrible depending on the outcome and
you're not in both cases you're not
factoring all of the chance involved
right so it seems to be a
fragile mindset in a sense it's a
vulnerable mindset there's a German
philosopher whose name I'm I'm I'm
forgetting but he has this idea and this
probably a pretty common idea I don't
know if he came up with this but he just
uh talked about it that there are an
infinite number of possible worlds an
infinite number of ways the world could
have turned out and we just happen to
live in this one there are just an
infinite number of alternative histories
that could have gone another way during
the Revolutionary War in the United
States it was the Battle of Long Island
and George Washington and his troops
were very close to being wiped out by
the British they basically had him
cornered just outside of Brooklyn and
all they had to do was sail up the East
River and it would all been over and
that was their plan and George
Washington were starving and hungry and
they were they were whipped and the
night that the British were planning to
sail up the river and Corner him the
winds change direction and turn the
other way and they could not sail up the
East River and that gave George
Washington and his troops just enough
time to get away David McCulla who is
one of the was one of the world's
foremost authorities on this topic was
interviewed by Charlie Rose and Charlie
Rose said if the winds were blowing the
other direction that night would there
have been any United States and David
McCulla said absolutely not
the entire reason this exists is because
the winds in Brooklyn change directions
last night when you hear enough stories
like that you realize this just like
literally nothing is certain about the
future it could all go in any different
direction for the tiniest little reason
not a big reason but for me it was it
was not going on a second run and by I I
thought about it afterwards I had
probably been on something like 3,000
runs with Brendan Brian over the course
of my life proba something in that
neighborhood and how many times did I
say hey you guys do another I'm going to
skip probably never I think it was
probably the first time I'd done
something like that and so when you when
you hear a story about the wind's
changing direction or for me it it just
makes you so incapable of having any
kind of confidence that we know what the
future is going to bring for any of
us let's maybe shift
to the metal level one more time and and
I'll make it more specific uh in terms
of the question about the questions and
then I want to uh segue to not in a rush
but asking about perhaps things that are
more inside of our control in terms of
coming back to the Serenity Prayer which
which you so kindly invented in 2020
although I guess the be here now you did
you did not that was from the canon in
terms of the past and the future in any
case work on that one yeah so these
questions like what are we ignoring
today that will seem shockingly obvious
in year were these questions that you
generated or
used mostly in think thinking about
investing are these prompts that you
came up with for
writing or something else where did
these questions come from let me start
with that specific question about what's
going to be shockingly obvious in the
year I remember I forget who it was but
it was during the dark days of coid
March or April 2020 and somebody tweeted
I I forget who it was but they said in
one year we're either going to be in the
Second Great Depression and it's going
to be so obvious that that was where we
were heading or we're going to be in a
giant boom and it's going to be so
obvious that that's where we were
heading either of those outcomes would
be so obvious and the truth is one year
later by most measures we were in a
giant boom stock market boom Eon like
things were exploding in 2021 the meme
stock bubble and for a lot of people it
was so obvious the FED printed all this
money we did $6 trillion dollar who
anyone could have seen this coming but
the truth is that if we were in the
Second Great Depression it would have
been just as obvious most of these
questions that I posed in the end of the
chapter there are questions that I think
are impossible to answer so what is
going to be shockingly obvious today one
year from now in 2024 I think it's
impossible to answer but it's going to
be shockingly obvious and and maybe the
answer will be who is going to win or
who's going to lose the presidency and
when it's going to happen it's going to
be so obvious a lot of people did this
with Trump in 2016 when he won they said
yeah I I saw this coming I maybe or if
if he had lost huge that would have been
obvious too so most of these questions I
just kind of have in my kind of semi-
depressive walks around the neighborhood
sometimes and I'm walking my dog
contemplating what what the past could
have been or what the future's going to
hold for me but I actually kind of enjoy
doing these things I think it's fun to
contemplate a world that is so outside
of your little Comfort bubble of what
you've
experienced so let me touch on another
one of the questions which is which of
our current views would change if our
incentives were different and I want to
tie it to
another line that I have in front of me
that I want you to elaborate on and
maybe these parw well maybe they don't
but but they seem like they could and it
is the most valuable personal finance
asset is not needing to impress anyone
I'll tell you what is so Stark to me
about about the topic of incentives
about how would I be different if my
incentives were different one of the
passages that I've read that stuck out
to me the most and stopped me dead in my
tracks was from this book on World War
II as we were just saying it's a book
called what we knew and it's a book that
interviews German civilians who are
around during Nazi Germany and the book
just ask what did you see what did you
know during this period did you know
about the Holocaust like just in a very
non-judgmental way because they're all
civilians just tell me what you saw and
there's a German
civilian who who mentions that when
Hitler came to power virtually every
German supported him and the interviewer
says like why what it was so appealing
and the the civilian says we have to
understand in 1920s in the early 1930s
the German economy was an utter
catastrophe way worse than the Great
Depression that we had in the United
States they had hyperinflation
everything fell to pieace pieces and hit
I'm simplifying this but Hitler came to
power and said I have a better way I'm
going to give you all jobs I'm going to
make you all wealthy again we're going
to restore German pride and power and in
that situation when everyone was
literally starving and had nothing this
civilian said if someone comes along and
promises you a better way you accept it
and you say yes I'll go with you and
they said everyone was so willing to
overlook the obvious downsides of Hitler
because he gave them the incentive to be
like hey do you want a job do you want
Pros I'm the way and they said sign me
up I'll do it there's another example of
a documentary in Mexico where El Chapo
was of course one of the most ruthless
murderous you know drug lords of all
time but he's actually very well
supported by a lot of local communities
in Mexico and they this interviewer ask
these people why why do you support this
murderous dictator and they said we got
to understand we have nothing we have no
money and Chapo comes to town and he
says I'll build you homes I'll I'll give
you Healthcare I'll give you food I'll
give you jobs takes care of all of them
and their incentive the civilians
incentive is to say this guy's great
love this guy so I think a lot of
society when you look at why was Hitler
supported why is Chapo supported can at
least in part be explained what by those
people have incentives that you and I
don't and what is scary but undoubtedly
true is contemplating whether you or I
if we lived in Germany in the 1930s or
if we lived in Mexico in the last 20
years would have supported those people
of course we would have yes I think you
are fooling yourself if you say no I
would not have and so I think it I think
if you have a cynical view of everyone
who lived in Germany was a monster of
course A lot of them were but if you see
they all were monsters everyone who
supports El Chapa is a
monster I think if your conclusion is
that all of them you are
misunderstanding the power of incentives
and how you would be different
yourself yeah I agree so let's use that
as a segue to maybe the unrelated maybe
the related the most Val valuable
personal finance asset is not needing to
impress anyone is that something you can
cultivate or is that also a preset out
of the box I think there are definitely
people who are more insecure than others
and I think where a lot of this comes
from is that everybody wants respect and
admiration from people around them
particularly the people who they want to
admire them their friends their spouses
their co-workers and there's a couple
different ways to cultivate that if you
can cultivate respect and admiration
through wisdom and intelligence and
humor and love and empathy then you can
then you can get all of it from that if
you don't have any of those traits most
people will resort to trying to gain
admiration with horsepower and square
footage and they'll just try to show off
to other people I can't gain your
respect with humor and wisdom but look
at my car it's really cool isn't it
that's a lot of where it comes from and
we were talking about comedians before
Louis CK I I'm fine saying this because
I think he would admit to it he's he
looks like a fat slob nobody cares
because he's so funny he doesn't need to
show off his six-pack he does if he
drove a Honda Civic nobody would care
they admire him because he's funny and I
think that's there's a lot of like
Insight in that that everybody just
wants respect and admiration I know
there was like a picture of Justin
Bieber the other day and he's wearing
like a dirty wife beater and like ripped
sweatpants doesn't matter he's Justin
Bieber he can do it does not matter if
you gain your respect and admiration
from other ways you don't need to show
it off and so I think that's a big part
of this and for the huge majority of
people the biggest Financial liability
that they have it's not student loans
it's not a mortgage it's their desire
and their need to impress other people I
think that the way that you can
cultivate this is realizing that those
people are a by and large not paying
attention to you they're worried about
themselves the people who like who you
think are looking at your car are not
they're thinking about their own car
that's a big part of this or the other
part of it is you know there's probably
seven people in my life who I want to
love me my parents my wife my kids one
or two friends that I would say I I
really desperately want them to love me
it's really important that they love me
and that's it the other the other 7.99
n99 billion people on the planet maybe I
I I would like you to like me but that's
that's about it so once you realize that
then it's like I want seven people to
really respect and admire me and I'm
gonna put all my effort into that and
everyone else I I really I really don't
have much care about I think once you
accept that it's a huge relief off your
shoulders
so you mentioned earlier the most
important decision of your life being
that snap decision to not take the extra
run very quickly either just before or
just after you mention that you talked
about marriage or who you
marry so how would you suggest people
think about
that if there is a way to think about it
or is it just a crapshoot right it's
just like hey look you're in the casino
and either you're going to roll Lucky
Sevens or you're not but best of luck to
you is there a structured way to think
about this or a particular way a mode of
thinking about this that that you could
any any suggestions asking for a
friend gun to my head Tim it's it's the
ladder I think I think a lot of it is
there's a a tremendous amount of luck
that's involved in it a lot of that is
because most people want to get married
during a pretty narrow window of their
life from probably age 25 to 35 is when
most people want to get married so
during that window you're really just
like who am I meeting and you meet
particularly as you get older a lot of
people are like I really want to get
married I just met this guy or this girl
like okay that's that's what I got we're
we're gonna marry that's that's what's
in front of me that's what we're going
to do I do think there is a sense though
that a lot of people particularly when
they're young particularly in their
early to mid 20s are obviously
maximizing for the wrong variables guys
are maximizing for beauty and women will
tend to maximize for money and Prestige
that's a very generalized statement that
is not black and white so if you're
offended by that I'm not talking about
you but obviously what's going to work
in the long run is just like are you
best friends with this person that's it
that's it I think there's analogy to
investing here where a lot of investors
want to maximize for the variable how do
I earn the highest returns this year and
in many ways that is like maximizing
free Beauty it's like super fun it's
super exciting right now I'm going to
get a lot of dopamine right now which is
what you'll get from an attractive
spouse it's what you'll get from like
owning a meme stock in 2021 but what
actually works in the long term is like
is owning a boring Index Fund for 50
years and what's actually going to work
in marriage is marrying your best friend
even if they're not the most attractive
or richest person that was in your
Social Circle I think that's that's like
really clear as day now there are some
people who will marry their best friend
who is also very wealthy and and very
attractive like of course like it works
out but I think a lot of it is just
people maximizing for the wrong
variables in there when I look at my own
marriage my wife and I met when she was
19 and I was 21 so we were very young we
were in
college and we've you know we've been
together for 17 or 18 years now and when
I look back at it I think it was it was
overwhelmingly luck and I think the
biggest element of luck in there is that
we grew together and hey by the way I'm
gonna say we've grown together so far
fingers crossed that we continue to do
so but if you understand what happens to
most relationship it's much more
difficult than you would think but I
attribute that a lot to luck and there
were periods in our relationship when I
started to go one way and she started to
go another and and we came back but you
can see it how did you do that could you
give maybe you don't have to give a
concrete example if it's not comfortable
but this is a relationship breaker that
Divergence breaks a lot of relationships
or it just causes an incredible amount
of strife and it's not clear that the
lines come back to converge right I've
seen
many seemingly great
relationships self- imilate because of
this Divergence that does not converge
into time to save the relationship so
what did you guys do to re it back in or
what happened there the best definition
I've heard about love is you love
someone if you respect them for their
faults as much as you do their good
traits what does that mean though I mean
it sounds good I'm going to push back a
little hard because I'm not like yeah
this person's always late I really
respect that they're always [__] late
when they show up to dinner no I I I
totally understand what you mean and I
think maybe respect is the wrong word
but it's more acceptance if my wife does
something that irritates me of course
that's happened and vice versa more so
vice versa I have to go out of my way
but I try to go out of my way to say I
know she means well I know she's doing
the best she can even if it really
bothered me and I think if if you if you
can hold on to that it's easier not to
look over things but to compromise on
things everyone knows the friendship
with your best buddy not your spouse or
your mate but your best buddy that all
it takes is for one person to pick up
the phone and give you a call and if you
can do that you can keep keep a
friendship going for 20 years 30 years
and I think
if one person in the relationship really
wants us to work you can really make it
work I I I have a close friend who their
relationship is not that healthy and
they have said that at any given time
one of them wants to leave but there's
never been a time when both of them want
to leave and that's why they stuck
together and so I think if there's one
person in the relationship that is
willing to compromise and make it work
there's a good chance that it's going to
work over time I pretty much have I
don't think I've ever I've ever said
this
I really have three major life goals I
want to stay married I don't want to get
fat and I want to be there for my kids
is that in weighted order one to three
probably not probably not I was kidding
but I think that's like respect for my
relationships respect for my body and
respect for my family is one other way
that you can put that and I think if
those are really the goals that if I'm
on my deathbed and I have not achieved
those I'm gonna have some regrets if
those are that powerful then you're
willing to compromise on a billion
different things to make it work yeah
and there's a friend of mine named Brent
bore who says if both you and your
spouse want to serve each other and
expect nothing in return then it works I
want to serve my wife and I don't expect
her to serve me and if both of you do
that you're always going to be
pleasantly surprised you're always going
to be like wow you did this for me
you're always going to be in the sense
of awe of the other person that is kind
of idealized of course it's much easier
to say than to do but I think it's a
pretty good guiding philosophy once you
be like I'm in the service industry I
want to try to serve my wife
and I I don't want to expect much in
return if I can do those things I'm
probably going to wake up pretty
satisfied with the relationship most
days that's probably true for Life
broadly speaking in the sense that
reality minus expectations equals of
state of being right yeah absolutely so
let me ask you a question that I brought
up a little bit earlier I'm just I've
never heard it posed or readit posed and
so I'm curious to know how you might
answer this this if you had a gun
against the head so I'm not saying this
is intended to immediately produce
answers but if you had to answer it or
answer it for other people What hassle
are you trying to eliminate that's
actually an unavoidable cost of success
and the reason that I want to return to
this is
that and this ties into the question of
money happiness contentment Etc is that
many people who achieve what would be
considered by most find financial
success are people who have been
rewarded for solving problems over long
periods of time and they probably
identify as being a good Problem Solver
and they are therefore conditioned their
behaviors are shaped to look for
problems to solve and that does not
always Foster a sense of well-being yeah
if that makes sense
so yeah What hassle are you trying to
eliminate that's actually an unavoidable
cost of success How would how would you
answer this or how have you answered it
or how have you seen other people come
up with answers we'll give you a
technical answer and then maybe a a a
more personal answer all right I think
when I wrote that question I was
probably thinking of stock market
volatility very technical probably not
where you thought I was going a lot of
investors try to eliminate volatility
and they say they view it as a burden
and something that you should get rid of
when actually it's like no that's the
cost of success right it's the fee and
not the penalty right it's the fee and
not the penalty that's probably what I
was thinking one thing that comes to
mind is a blog post that you wrote many
years ago I think about the cost of Fame
yeah 11 reasons why not to become famous
MH and you were very open and
forthcoming about what it's done to your
own life and Anyone who reads that will
read that and
say some version of I I don't envy what
Tim's going through and the irony of
coming to that conclusion after millions
of people will look at the books that
you sold and the money that you've made
and the downloads of your podcast would
say I want to be like Tim and you read
that it's like bye I don't know maybe
but I don't know it's not at all clear
anymore among the top 10 richest people
in the world there are I think 14
cumulative divorces which is is
obviously like a massive outlier within
there and I think I think the reason why
that is is because to become very
successful you need to devote every
waking hour to your career and so your
spouse your children your friends like
bye like sorry don't don't have any time
for you if you read the biography of the
snowball which I I reread recently it's
of Warren Buffett as someone who's been
such a Buffett Fanboy my entire life and
a lot of people will fall into that
category you read his biography and at
the end you're like to tell you the
truth not the life that I want yeah he
has devoted every waking hour since he's
been 11 years old to picking stocks
that's not an exaggeration and it came
at the expense of his personal life his
marriage his
children there was an interview with
Elon mus several years ago where they're
talking about how hard he works and he
breaks down in tears and he says all of
this has come at the expense of coming
with of spending time with my children
and it's like I I I don't want that I I
there's never there's not any version of
life in which I would be on my deathbed
and say that was worth it I made a ton
of money but who are these children that
I had I don't even know them and so I
think if you if you want the success but
you want to eliminate the downsides of
it you're completely fooling yourself
you you have to make a decision I would
be willing to bet too although I don't
want to put words in your mouth that
despite that blog post when you're
talking about all of the downside that
you have experienced if you had to go
back to before when you wrote 4our work
week you would not change your mind you
would still do it that the cost was
worth it I don't want to put words in
your mouth but I'm willing to bet that's
true you know I would say
it's it's a both end there are ways in
which it is worth it and there are many
ways in in which it is not worth it and
that's what makes it so
tricky on a forward-looking basis
thinking about decisions although it's
it's easier for me now because I've
realized the fan some of the fan
Bargains
and I've also
realized how to your earlier Point how
much money is an amplifier rather than a
savior if that makes sense and of course
it depends on where you are on Ma's
hierarchy of needs but chances are if
you're listening to this
podcast and you've made it however long
hour hour and a half that using the
global average as a reference point you
are in the top 1% and you are doing very
well from a global standpoint
and well i' I'd say a few things just to
give myself a a little bit of slack the
younger self that I don't think hope is
Trivial and that that seems like such a
self-evidence statement but this is this
is part of why and I'm not sure if we
talked about this but uh there are some
people I've come across who are like ah
lotteries you know lotteries are taxes
on the dumb and I think about it I'm
like well if if you feel trapped if you
don't have mobility
and 10 bucks when the Powerball gets
over $500 million buys you a week or a
couple of days of Hope and excitement is
that really a bad investment I would I
would actually push back and say it's
actually probably not a bad investment
it's actually a great investment as long
as you don't overdo it and
similarly I think that without the
delusion early on that money would fix
all of these problems and all of it
would resolve all of this inner conflict
and turmoil and in security without I I
think that was actually a very valuable
delusion yeah what was my alternative
right compared to what I think is a
question we need to ask more often right
risky compared to what is it this
compared to what is that person a good
match compared to what and for me it was
like all right what was the best
alternative to just not have any hope to
assume that this like steady state of at
the time you know quite a bit of
suffering and depression was going to
last
forever I don't think that was a viable
alternative right so even though I've
arrived at a point where I need to find
other Solutions I think that's better
than having given up hope you 20 30
years
ago but I would have made some very
different tactical decisions along the
way to minimize some of the risks and
downsides for sure but it's It's Tricky
even if that's in hindsight definitely
true I think it would have been
impossible because there's no way for
you to learn about the downsides of Fame
other than to go through them so like it
almost would have been very difficult to
preempt it I think there are some things
to do back to the8 billion doll family
they learned vicariously through other
families what not to do yeah and they
preempted a lot of it so to the extent
that you can learn those mistakes from
other people people and I would say
reading that blog post from you Tim had
a profound impact on me and I think what
a lot of people who are in any degree of
public Spotlight don't understand is
that you think you're gaining attention
but what you're actually fostering is
envy and envy will come back to haunt
you tenfold yeah and so like be very
careful when you put your when you put
your successes out there because even
for people who are clapping for you
they're clapping for you while they're
biting their lip because they're envious
of what you
and even if they don't feel that Envy in
the moment the and I may have mentioned
this in that piece but it's like the the
poles the extreme switch sides very
easily although it tends to be
unidirectional in the sense that the
people who are your
biggest most extreme fans have the most
dedication
are in my experience this is not my own
experience this I've spoken to a lot of
people who would reinforce this they can
switch to being the most
violent terrifying attackers very easily
and that can get physically dangerous I
mean there are many examples of that I
don't have to get into it but that
particular set of experiences has also
led me to rethink honestly the podcast
in the sense that to to compete and I'm
less and less interested in competing in
most things although by Nature I'm very
competitive I enjoy comp cheating I
enjoy winning I guess is a better way to
put it or maybe I just hate losing who
knows we can psychoanalyze that another
time but the to compete right
now you need to as a podcaster in this
type of format not true crime there are
exceptions Like This American Life but
if you are interview format if you
really want to compete you basically
have to produce a television show and
one I think of the
mostly hidden risks which is kind of
obvious I think in retrospect when
people look back a year or 5 years from
now it will seem very obvious and
they'll say well how could it have
turned out any different but the risks
of video micro fame or macro Fame and
the degree to which a much higher
percentage of the population is going to
be subject to stalkers and death threats
and very very very scary things people
showing up at their homes because they
bought it in their own name and not
through an C or trust or whatever that
that I think is going to be
a cost that a lot of folks are not
seeing down the pike that I think is is
unavoidable so for me personally
particularly as I shift into new
chapters in my life I've been thinking
about meditating on writing on quite
extensively how I want to adapt or stop
or modify what I'm doing to mitigate
some of those risks because I do view
them as
unavoidable and I I just don't think
most people having never experienced
that having never been in a car crash
they're like what do you mean a car
crash like sure I'll wear my seat belt
but I don't have to pay attention to a b
and c and d factors it's like no you
probably should because the downside
risk is so high anyway not to paint a
dark picture I think a lot of these
things can be avoided but the Temptation
like you said and the performative
aspect of so much of this on say social
media and the reinforcement and the way
that these platforms have been designed
to take advantage of the baser drives
and fears that humans have is remarkable
they're very well tuned yeah maybe it's
easy for me to say right because I've
had enough success on say the podcast
that I could afford to pull the cord if
I wanted and do something else that's
what's most interesting to me are the
people the young people on social media
who are very reasonably like waving
their arms to get attention because they
don't have any attention yet and they're
they're trying to break through I see
this with a lot of new people on Twitter
a lot of new bloggers new podcasters how
do you stand out you stand out by being
ridiculous a lot of new politicians by
the way some of whom are running for
office right now if you're not a
household name how do you become one by
saying the most ridiculous thing
possible so that's like when attention
is the currency and the only way to
become wealthy in that sense is to is to
do something like so far out of the norm
and Norm breaking you know it's a really
dangerous world to live in I see because
you know social media came to be when I
was in my early 20s but I see my son
who's seven and is already interacting
with YouTube not any other social media
platforms but even in YouTube The
Influence that it has on him is
astounding and growing up with Mr Beast
which I think is like reasonably
wholesome content for young people to
watch it's not that bad but even that I
can see see what it does to his
expectations and I see what it does to
his Ambitions and I see what it does to
his willingness to want to put on a
prank video or his willingness to want
to catch people's attention by doing
something absurd it's like that is a
pretty unhealthy mindset to learn from a
young age and I think every child is
learning it today it's just what's being
shoved down their throats in social
media yeah and also it's like on the
spectrum of things as a male or a
female what you're trying to do to get
attention how close is it to say a
modeling career and how close is it to
say being a professor which are very
different
things and you could use different
fill-ins for that but like the closer
you are to model or professional athlete
right let's just say you're doing
something that is very physically
intensive that you can only sustain for
a short period like the longevity of
that career is going to be very short
until the newer vintage comes in to
replace you which they will so also
thinking about like what the nature of
the attention is and what's involved and
what the longevity is which frankly even
when I was in my early 20s I probably
wouldn't have been terribly receptive to
hearing yeah you know if I were if I
were an attractive woman I could just
show my ass and get to the point where
I'm making you tens of thousands of
dollars a month by for holding energy
drinks in my photos like I mean who am I
to say I wouldn't do it I I think
there's a good chance I would have I
think it's super dangerous in any life
to attach your identity to something
that's unsustainable whether it's being
a model or having a certain career
having an investing strategy if you
attach your identity for to something
that you cannot sustain when it ends
you're going to be morally crushed it's
just going to destroy you and this like
back to investing the variable that I
want to maximize for is how long can I
do this for it's not can I earn the
highest returns it's can I maintain this
investing strategy for another 50 years
and I I know that I couldn't earn a
higher return this year and over the
next five years if I did something
different but I'm way less confident
that I could keep it going and sustain
it and I think it's the same for
relationships like you might be able to
find a more attractive or a wealthier
spouse or partner but can you keep that
going is it something you can maintain
that's I think I I'm not interested in
anything that's not sustainable
friendships investing careers podcasts
reading habits exercise habits if I
can't keep it going I'm not interested
in it and I think the only way to really
do that is if you are going out of your
way to live life at like 80 to 90%
potential
if you're always trying to sze out 100%
potential for something almost certainly
it's going to lead to burnout whether
it's a friend or relationship or
investing strategy so I think it's not
easy thing to do and if you're a type a
person it's almost impossible to do but
going out of your way to live life at
80% has always been a strategy that I I
want to do just because I want to keep
it going for a long time as we're
talking about I've
never really mentioned this publicly
but in my experience of having various
chapters in my career and life so far it
seems like in my case if I'm trying to
peek around corners and adopt I wouldn't
say Cutting Edge but sort of dull Edge
Technologies I'm never the I'm very
rarely the first I mean there's some
examples of me doing things very early
but generally if you look at say Angel
Investing right like the Angel Investing
had had existed for a decent actually a
very long time in Silicon Valley terms
but there wasn't and there were a
handful of let's call the micro VCS but
beyond that there was a a pretty wide
open field
for advising and investing and so I was
I don't know let's call it like number
100 to the field but there was a period
where the game was kind of like Google
AdWords in the very beginning I wasn't
the first to use Google AdWords but man
was there a golden period for like three
to five years where everything seemed to
work and that's not true in Angel
Investing but a lot of things worked I
also got very lucky with timing but I
look at that it's like okay my sweet
spot was really from like 2008 to 2012
but let's push it out from like 2008 to
2015 it was about 7 years and then it
became really popular everyone with an
audience started building VC funds and
man oh man did that game get hard money
came in from China at one point terms
started getting really wild valuations
went ballistic and I was like okay I was
playing with like single deck Blackjack
and now it's like five deck
Blackjack this is a much harder game to
play and so I stopped for an extended
period of time then you look at
podcasting it's like okay I started in
2014 I would say the main meat and
potatoes earning potential growth
potential was in the first seven years
podcast is still doing great but I'm
coming up on the 10th anniversary and
the game has become very very very
challenging in and to anyone who's being
honest at the higher end in the
podcasting game will tell you a lot of
brands have been cutting back due to
global macro factors a lot of the
studios who have raised money for
podcasting and part of the reason you
see you still see podcast growth but a
lot of it is because these studios are
putting out 50 new shows they're not
necessarily focusing on making the next
Charlie Rose and doubling and tripling
down single shows there are some
examples of that and there are some
great shows out there but the discovery
problem for listeners and the
competitive problem and many other
factors have made this for me again
reminiscent of Angel Investing when I
started to think you
know part of being good at a game is
choosing the right game and and part of
what makes the right game is the right
competitive landscape and the right
ratio of sort of opportunity to cost and
risk and the podcasting game is getting
very hard
and it's it's getting dragged into
territory because of platform
competition let's just say you know
Instagram and YouTube and so on
versus Tik Tok this short form or video
reward system incentive system it's
pulling people like me or others in a
direction where inevitable cost fixed
costs being in single locations which
are all antithetical to the reasons why
I started in the first place and I saw
this also with with the Angel Investing
it's like wait a second I'm being forced
now into a position where I'm heavily
tempted to do things that are counter
completely to the strategies that have
worked for me up to this point do I want
to adapt and end up being one of a
thousand people trying to do the same
thing or do I want to try something
different so I'm just observing this
sort of if I choose really
well the the shelf life for for a lot of
what I have done seems to be 5 to 10
years and then in let's just say the
last 50% of that I need to have my eyes
open for what the next chapter looks
like that could give me perhaps that
type of Runway right like 5 to 10 years
which is different in a way from what
you're describing but I'm just observing
that in my own experience let me ask you
this and we can of course take this
wherever you'd like
but where do you think text goes from
here because I I think that all that is
old becomes new once again you look at
substack you look at any number of these
things like yeah text has been sort of
the redheaded stepchild wasn't sexy but
you look at the success of say Matt
LaVine incredible right you look it
still works and text still travels even
though the platforms if we look at those
social media platforms as necessary
which I think is a question mark
actually Tex is not going to necessarily
be as heavily rewarded as the things
that they're prioritizing to meet their
own quarterly goals and so on but where
do you think textas goes in the next
handful of years here's what's so
shocking to me in in my experience the
audio book version of psychology money
outsells the physical book The text book
by two to one never in a million years
what I have thought that because I'm a
book reader I read physical books
especially for that kind of book I know
it's Bonkers but talking to other
authors it's similar the number of
people who are willing to get their
content through their ears versus
through their eyes is way bigger reading
is hard for most people it's a slog they
have to reread paragraphs but listening
is great it's also single tasking right
it's a single activity whereas the
listening in an attention economy where
people are trained to feel there is a
scarcity of time yes the other
experience I've had is that because of
that experience with the audiobook four
months ago I started a podcast and I've
put virtually no effort into it I've
done like 14 episodes they're all about
10 minutes long that podcast is already
larger than my blog that I've been
working on for 16 years it just exploded
which is kind of depressing but I think
it just goes back to the audience that's
willing to listen is way bigger than the
audience that will read now I do think
it's the case that not only is reading
hard but writing is hard it's easier to
speak than it is to write in text so the
people who are good at it will always
have an audience that will always be
there if if you write a textbook if you
start blogging again as he said you
would you'll have an instant audience
because you're good at it but I think
there are a lot of people I would be
willing to bet without knowing this I'd
be willing to bet that Joe Rogan is not
a good
writer but he's a very good speaker and
so they're just very different skills
they're very different I will say that I
actually think Joe if he wanted to make
it a high priority would be a very good
writer as a comedian that might be the
case and I'm probably being unfair I
think it'd be good but I do think they
are very different skills they can be
mutually exclusive yes they don't have
to come as a pair yeah there are people
who are good writers and not good
speakers and vice versa so I think that
the people who try to do both will by
and large be not that great at either of
them and I think that I think most
people should probably try to pick one
or the other when I started my podcast I
thought 90% chance it's not going to
work now i' put those odds at like 6 %
chance it's not going to work just
because I've always been a writer I like
typing that's when I think I do my best
work I think there's always going to be
a market for either and the content
creators who are going to screw
themselves are the people who try to be
everything to everybody you know most
most book publishers want authors to
narrate their own audiobooks and I
haven't done it for either of my books
because it's not my skill and I want to
pass it to someone whose skill it is and
it's always been astounding to me that
they want authors who are not good
speakers
to do it even if they're not that good
at it so it's I I I think that's an
analogy for where where text is going
too I just I'm laughing because I
thought of this story hope I'm not
speaking out of school here um but I'm
pretty sure he he he's mentioned it
publicly AJ Jacobs who's an amazing
writer he wrote The Year of Living
biblically he's written many books that
I think are very very smart they're also
very very funny you could I recommend
people check out also an Esquire piece
he wrote called I think you're fat which
is an experiment in radical
honesty such a good title great writer
he said to me when he was persuaded to
read his own audiobook he went in for
the recording session and a few hours in
they said look AJ why don't you just go
home get some
rest take some decongestants and we'll
see you when you're feeling better and
he's like what do you mean feeling
better this is just my
[Music]
voice something along those lines it was
so funny we are not all designed to read
audiobooks but let me come back to text
versus
audio and this is going to be hard to
get from any analytics so there's going
to be some guess work involved
but do you
value a read of say one of your blog
posts in the same way that you value a
single listen of a podcast episode and
embedded in this is do you think they
are the same audience I know they are
not the same audience or is it like
speaking at a general business
conference versus speaking at Ted where
you get maybe 10,000 people in the first
and a th000 people at the second but
that does not mean the latter is
automatically worth 10% of the
former it's definitely not the same
audience and the reason I know that is
because every podcast episode I do I'm
reading an old blog post and nobody
cares because the people who are
listening to it did not read the blog
post and so so for them it's all brand
new content I just came up some of these
block post I wrote 10 years ago but it's
all new to them and so I know it's not
the same and I think there are people
like myself I will listen to podcasts on
planes and that's it but other than that
I I just read when I'm home I never
listen to anything I just read and even
at night when I'm falling to sleep I can
try Netflix for a little bit but really
what I want to do is read a book and for
me I think the reason why I like reading
better is because it's easier to zip
your eyes up and reread a paragraph than
it is to rewind and try to figure and
like what what what that guy just say
it's easier to just zip your to read it
again and so I think you absorb a lot
more of it by reading at least that's
true for me so I would be shocked if I
deviated from that I I think I'll be
reading text forever and and I think I
I'll want to be a writer forever even if
my podcast were to become very
successful I think I would say I'm I'm
I'm a writer I'm curious what your
thought is that because you were a very
successful writer before you started the
podcast yeah if you go back to 2013
before your podcast started would you
have shaken your head in disbelief at
the idea that you didn't abandon writing
but you became much more of a speaker
than a
writer I certainly wouldn't have seen it
coming I started this podcast as an
experiment I think I committed to six
episodes to see if I could refine
my conversational skills question asking
reduce my stammering and get rid of some
verbal ticks with the assumption that
even if I stopped after six episodes
that would help me with my interviewing
for non-fiction writing yeah so I
couldn't have foreseen
it having done so many interviews prior
to starting the podcast I had confidence
that I could do interviewing well but I
never could have foreseen the
podcast getting to a billion downloads
right I mean that's just not that would
have been so far outside of any mental
schema for thinking about anything that
I would do
it would it wouldn't have occurred to me
when you think about the Arc of your
career would you put the podcast above
the 4-Hour Work Week in terms of
importance and success however you want
to measure that I don't think I
would because if I separate them out
into discreet independent pieces I think
that's a mistake since there was a
domino effect and without that first
Domino the second the third and the
fourth Domino don't tip over so I would
have to still give the 4our work week by
far love it or hate it for me blessing
and the
curse that is what made everything
subsequently possible so I still have to
give the 4-Hour Work
Week the vast majority of of credit
remarkably that book and probably tools
of Titans are my two bestselling books
still to this day and I would say a
third probably almost all of the tools
referenced in in the 4-Hour Work week or
out of date and that makes me very happy
though because the the philosophical
backbone the the core fundamental pieces
are Timeless in a sense they they really
don't have an expiration date so I've
been very pleased to see that but it's
it's nonetheless remarkable that the
book continues to be read and
recommended despite the fact that I'm
telling people to go to a magazine rack
and use various tools to determine
readership of magazines as a way of
sizing audience I mean that's Model T or
maybe the horse horse drawn carriage
compared to what we can do today so at
some point perhaps I'll update that but
that's a losing game also updating tools
is just a losing game I could have
updated three years ago and then chat
GPT and other llms come along and I have
to do a complete revision after that so
I assume the principles will enable
people to find the tools but the the
podcast I would say certainly at this
this
point nine out of 10 people who come up
to me on the street will mention the
podcast and will not mention any book
yeah that's astounding which is
astounding nonetheless I do think the
Decay rate on the podcast is much higher
and will be on a on a
totality much faster than the book in
other words not only will people forget
a given episode they will forget that I
had a podcast or anything related to my
podcast I think much faster than they
will the books simply because there're
so much [__] noise there's so much
the replacement rate is so high and
people can only hold so much in their
heads myself included so the sort
of you know first in first
out sort of mental archiving is such
that I do think if I stop podcasting
today and people continued listening to
podcasts who were devout listeners of
the Tim Farah show I think they would
forget about the Tim ferah show within a
few years one or two years if I'm being
optimistic whereas I do think the books
for whatever reason seem to
have a more
persistent enduring foothold in the mind
than do the podcast even even if it's a
the best episode I've ever put out
doesn't matter I don't disagree with it
I'm just trying to figure out why that
would be and maybe it's because in a
book if it's 20 chapters that's all you
got it's just 20 chapters in front of
you so it it gives the impression or the
truth that what is there is profound
whereas if you open up Apple podcasts
there are three million podcasts or
whatever there is and each of those has
dozens or hundreds of episodes It's so
much in there that it's hard to take any
single bit of it seriously maybe that's
true for books too you walk into Barnes
& Noble there's a million books in there
as well but when you're holding a book
it's like this is all that's in front of
me right now and so I need to pay
attention to every word whereas a
podcast it's just a living breathing
thing and you know I if if you watch the
the Daily News particularly like 247
cable news none of it should be that
profound because there's just so much of
it if you're just if you're just
constantly updating people on the news
of the hour odds are it's it's not that
important whereas if there was a one
hour newscast per
year that was updating you on the most
important news of the previous 12 months
it would be very important you have to
watch that it's very very important so I
think a lot of it is just the scale that
it's much easier to make a podcast
episode than it is to publish a book
chapter in physical form yeah I agree
with that I mean the spitballing ideas I
also think that if someone
commits
to reading a book if they finish it
especially if the assumption is buying a
non-fiction book that is prescriptive in
its advice is that you're going to take
action after a book there are a few
things that happen in the process of
doing that number one you're
contextualizing the book for your own
life as you go number two you're
harnessing sunk cost fallacy in a sense
because you have put more time into this
book I think you are more likely to try
to take some type of action to justify
that investment yeah also with the book
and single tasking you have captive
attention and I think people are more
engaged this is true for a novel versus
say a film
also in co-creating the visual
experience of traveling through these
pages
and then when people if they take action
after reading a book that is an
extension of the experience of reading
the book and is forever associated with
that book yeah as are I think Downstream
effects of those first steps whereas
listening to a podcast I think the
preset mentality coming into it this is
true for me too when I'm listening to a
podcast is I'm listening to something
while I'm going for a walk while doing
something else and I am absorbing
information but the expectation is not
given the Absurd volume of podcasts out
there and also just the Absurd volume of
podcast and audiobooks that I listen to
the Assumption I think in my mind is
passive ingestion less than I'm going to
take some notes and actually commit to
making meaningful change in my life
after I listen to this podcast I wish
were different agree yeah it's
definitely true like when I do listen to
podcasts it's it's pleasure and I think
when I read books I'm like I really want
to learn something here and take notes
and highlight it and readwise and and
really get something out of this what I
what I did start doing recently that's
been very helpful is when I'm listening
to a podcast and I hear something that's
really profound I'll just screenshot it
and therefore I have it timestamped of
like oh on Tim's podcast at 1 minute and
23 seconds and then I'll go back and
find the transcript and like try to try
to take notes that way that's been the
best note-taking process that I've had
for podcast to try to gain more insight
out of it rather than just passive
pleasure speaking of
books so let's let's go through a list
and I'd love for you to pick one or two
we can certainly talk about all of them
but uh great books that you've read
lately triangle fire Empty Mansions the
strange last Voyage of Donald curst and
then one that is a little cryptic Robert
Carol if I'm getting the pronunciation
right comma working I don't know what
that refers to maybe we start there
because I believe that is the author of
the power broker yep could you maybe
start with Robert and what that what
that refers to Robert Caro is probably
the greatest biographer of all time he's
certainly the most thorough biographer
of all time most of his books take
between 10 and 30 years for him to write
he's done biography on Lyndon Johnson
and Robert Moses who was an instrumental
figure in building the modern New York
City and he's just ridiculously thorough
and so he wrote a book called working
which is his life and practice and
strategy as a writer like like how did
he become a writer and how does he do it
and you realize that his talent is just
patience like he will sit in an archive
for 15 years and he has this motto turn
every page so he talks about when he
decided to do a biography of of Lynden
Johnson the first thing that he did is
he moved his wife to the middle of
nowhere Texas where Lyndon Johnson grew
up and he said there's no way that he
could understand the man unless he lived
in the town that he grew up in like
understanding wife exactly there's a
funny quote where his wife said why
couldn't you have done a biography of
Napoleon and they could have like moved
to Paris or something so he moved there
and he goes to the Lynden Johnson
Presidential Library and there's I think
it's literally like 8,000 boxes of
material and he goes through every page
he goes through every page it takes him
decades to do this and so there's just
no one that is as thorough as sounds
like a prison sense seriously but I
think he loves every second of it I
think the hunt for him is incredible so
even with something like Lynden Johnson
Robert Moses is a little more obscure
but everybody knows Lyndon his life was
so well documented but Robert kro will
find these nuggets that no one else has
ever uncovered before and I like I have
so much admiration for that in terms of
sticking out as a writer and doing
something different a crazy stat that
I've always you can take this several
different ways but there are 1,100
biographies of Winston Churchill
published biographies of the same person
talking about the same life but I bet
there's like 50 of those that really
stand out because they found a different
angle they found a different fact or
they told a better story so Robert Carol
I I think here's how I'd phrase this Ken
Burns who does the documentaries his
skill is telling a story and most of the
information in his documentaries is
already well known about the Civil War
World War II whatever it would be it's
not new information but he tells such a
good story that it's captivating and
you're going to watch it Robert
Caro and I mean this with the most
respect is not the best Storyteller but
his ability to uncover new information
is unparalleled completely unparalleled
to everyone else so I I admire him that
like his skill is just he works harder
and he's more patient than any other
writer that's ever
existed is there anything else that you
took from that book that you have
applied or hoped to apply to your own
writing or creative process one of it
that I think think this and I'm not
saying this to blow smoke but it reminds
me of you is that in his interviewing
process when he's interviewing people he
would always just stop and say tell me
more tell me more keep going tell me
more there's one scene from the book
where he's talking about lynon he's
interviewing Lyndon Johnson's chauffeur
who was with him for like 30 his entire
career as a politician Lyndon Johnson
did the same driver and so he this
driver saw everything and Robert Carol
says tell me like when Lyndon Johnson
was in the backseat of of the car when
he was campaigning what was he doing and
the shower's like I don't know I wasn't
paying attention but he just kept asking
no no tell me more what was he doing
what was he talking about what' he do
and he kep kept getting the answer I
don't know I wasn't paying attention and
finally after like weeks of asking the
same question the chauffeur says you
know what after campaign rallies Lyndon
Johnson would talk to himself in the
backseat of the car and he would say to
himself mumbling to himself this worked
this didn't I need to get better at this
I need to double down on this and like
that's fascinating that he would talk to
himself and it took Robert Carroll weeks
of asking the same question before he
got to that like a black sight
interrogation just wearing him down yes
but I think that's true for everyone and
I think a lot of it is if you asked me
what did I do last week I'd say say I
don't I don't really remember but if you
kept asking I probably did something
that was meaningful to me like if you
kept asking and kept pushing then the
memories start to Bubble Up and I think
Robert Carol is just a pro at
that so what if these other books maybe
we pick one if you had to pick two from
this list so triangle fire Empty
Mansions the strange last Voyage of
Donald Crower or maybe you can give just
a a very brief not to leave people
hanging what are these books and then if
you had to pick one more if you could
only pick two for you personally from
this list what the other one would be
yeah here's what's really interesting
about the triangle fire I think most if
not everyone here listening to this
knows what the triangle fire is I have
no idea oh that's okay this is great
then it was a fire and uh the triangle
shirt Waste Company in New York City
which was a company in the I think it
was 1911 that was making you're saying
everybody knows about this I feel like
an idiot I've never never heard anything
about this okay no this is even better
then it was a fire that took place in
this shirt garment Factory in New York
City and it was in the middle of the
workday and there were several hundred
they were all virtually all young women
who are buil who were making shirts in
New York City in 1911 and a fire took
place on the factory
and the the punch line of the story is
very very tragic I think 200 of them
died a lot of them jumped out of the
ninth story building the building is now
I think it's either part of or right
next to NYU it's the building still
exists and there's a plaque in front of
the building but it it was horrendous
several hundred of them burned to death
several dozen of them jumped out of the
building it was absolutely horrendous
and I think until 911 it was the
deadliest fire in in New York City
deadliest burning fire it was just an
utter tragedy and when I saw a book
about this I had I had heard about this
in documentaries and whatnot but I
thought how can you make a 250 page book
about a fire that from start to finish
was 30 minutes how do you make a book
like there's got to be so much rambling
in here and there wasn't because
actually the actual fire was just a seed
of a much bigger story which was after
the Triangle shirt Wass fire what
happened is all of the fire Escapes in
the building were locked intentionally
so that the workers these women could
not take an unscheduled break it was
literally literally lock you in a room
to work so when there was a fire they
all went to the fire escapes and they
were locked and those women either
burned to death or jumped out of the
building and so this set off this
unbelievable moral Panic across the
United States of worker rights and one
of the witnesses of the fire who stood
on the sidewalk and watched the women
jump out of the building was a young
woman named Francis Perkins and Francis
Perkins a lot of people will know that
name she became FDR's Secretary of Labor
she was the first female cabinet member
of any Administration and she was so
moved by the triangle fire as were so
many other people that after she
witnessed it she said I'm going to
devote my life to worker rights and
after a century or more several
centuries of just horrendous Sweatshop
conditions the triangle fire was the
impetus that was needed to start all
kinds of worker rights and there's a
quote from Francis Perkins when she said
without the triangle fire there would
have been no New Deal the New Deal of of
worker rights in the 1930s that moved
everything so much progress in the world
starts when something very tragic
happens
and starts on things are really bad the
Great Depression World War II the
triangle fire so much Innovation and
Improvement comes from those because
there is no motivation in life more than
just shock and necessity so the triangle
fire as tragic and awful as it was it
really was the reason that we have so
many workplace protections and within a
year or two of the triangle fire there
were all kinds of new laws in New York
City about worker rights and simple
things like fire escape and whatnot that
didn't exist until that happened so
that's why you can take a 30 minute fire
and turn it into a 250 page book is
because what the triangle fire sparked
in terms of worker rights in America was
unprecedented
fascinating what book or books have you
reread many times what's in the top five
list if any come to mind for books that
you've read not just read twice but more
than twice I'm pretty sure sure I've
read Doris Kern's no ordinary day three
times which I think it's 710 Pages it's
a very meaty book and I think I'm very
confident that each three times I read I
read to the last page one thing I would
say is that I always use that book as an
example as brevity does not mean short
because that book is 710 pages and every
single sentence needs to be there it's
about FDR and Elanor during World War II
and it's specific Al about their home
life not the decisions that he made
during the war it's about like the
emotions that he was going through
during that period that he and Eleanor
went through during World War II and
it's fascinating because you think of
the pressure on somebody like that of of
course today we know the outcome but FDR
never knew the outcome he died two weeks
before Germany surrendered so during
this entire period he really feels and
he's right that the fate of the world is
on his shoulders the decisions that he's
that he makes is literally the outcome
of humanity
and it was as stressful as you would
imagine so the book just goes through
what he went through how he managed
stress who he surrounded himself with
and there's so many just incredible
little anecdotes about how he lived his
life and what he did for example every
single evening I think at 6 PM no matter
what was going on that day no matter how
stressful or important the day was he
shut everything down and he brought two
or three friends into this little Dark
Room in the White House where he would
have a drink and his rule was no
politics do not say a single word about
politics we're here to talk about life
and friendship and movies and books and
he did it every day at 6 pm and I think
if he didn't do that he would have lost
his mind he would it would just been too
much and so like that there's all these
little anecdotes about that that I that
I really admire I'll tell you one little
other anecdote that really stuck with me
for this book on the night before dday
so almost nobody in the world knows
what's going to happen he and Elanor do
and he's talking to Elanor and he asks
her he says how does it feel to not know
what's going to happen tomorrow like
like literally the fate of the world
realiz on what what's going to happen
tomorrow morning and nobody else knows
it but us and Elanor says to be 60 and
still rebel against uncertainty is a bit
ridiculous isn't
it I love that quote she's like if
you've made it to age 60 and you're
rebelling against uncertain like what
like of course we don't know what's
going to happen and there's nothing we
can do about it so just go to bed
Franklin all these little anes that
beyond the content I think it's one of
the best written books ever like I said
it's 700 pages in every sentence needs
to be there Doris Kerns Goodwin is a
remarkable historian and writer she's
amazing yeah she and I had a really fun
conversation on this podcast actually a
few years ago she's an absolute gem yeah
which I recommend people check out also
Ken Burns we had a conversation about
his creative process which I encourage
people to check out let me ask and then
I promise we'll move on this title this
is proba the one that I would have
picked up
because it has a for me at least a very
seductive title The Strange last Voyage
of Donald curst what is this one of the
most interesting people that is not very
well known and to set the stage here
there was a boat race in 1968 that took
place in England it was sponsored by a
local newspaper and it was the first
person to sail around the world solo
wins
£5,000 and actually nobody in human
history had ever sailed around the world
solo so the first person to win this
race is going to be crowned the greatest
sailor of all time Donald kohur was at
best an amateur sailor he was like a
weekend warrior and he had kind of been
a failure at everything he had done in
his adult life he was a failed
businessman he got kicked out of the
army for insubordination he was a he
failed out a pilot school and he kind of
viewed this race as like his last shot
at Redemption his last shot to like
prove to the world that he was worthy of
their attention and their respect so he
sets s this this guy who really doesn't
know what he's doing he actually built
his own boat which he didn't know he was
doing there either and he sets sail and
like to his credit he makes it pretty
far he makes it like halfway down the
coast of Africa and then his boat
Springs a leak he can bail out with a
bucket it's not a catastrophic leak but
he knows that if he keeps sailing like
he's screwed he's G he's gonna sink and
die because at like in the southern
Atlantic the waves are much bigger so he
knows he's done so now he's like okay I
can either turn around and go home and
face shame and humiliation or I can keep
sailing and die and then he's like no
actually there's he's by himself doing
this in his diary he's like no there's
actually a third option here which is
fraud and deceit and so what he did is
he turned his boat around and he sailed
right into the middle of the Atlantic
Ocean where the waves were like very
calm and Placid and he drifts in circles
aimlessly for six months and all the
while he's doing this he's sending fake
radio communication back to England to
make it seem like he's still sailing
around the world he would literally send
back a radio communication be like Oh
I'm I'm passing the faulon islands
here's what they look like it was all a
scam he was drifting aimlessly in the
Atlantic his plan was to kill enough
time doing this that he he could have
plausibly sailed around the world and
then sail back to England with his
dignity intact and like just tell people
that I sailed around the world I did it
and then after six months he starts to
sail back to England and he realizes
that the other Sailors had taken so long
to sail around the world that he's going
to sail back to England as the winner
he's actually going to win this race or
at least appear to win this race and he
realizes that that's a catastrophe
because he's going to get so much
attention that they're going to uncover
his fraud they're going to scrutinize it
they're going to scrutinize it and he's
done so now he's he's very mentally
unstable at this point as anyone for six
months at Sea alone would be so he
realizes the gig is up and I'll I'll cut
to the Chase and get to the punch line
his body was never found his boat was
found but the only plausible kind of
accepted outcome is that after he
realized it was all up he threw himself
into the ocean and took his own life and
to me it's a very astounding story of
someone who was so
obsessed with gaining the respect and
admiration of other people all he wanted
to do was for other people to admire him
that's it he wanted that so badly that
he was willing to have the six-month
fraud to deceive everybody and when it
didn't work he just decided that life
wasn't worth living and that to me is
like just an astounding mental state
that someone would want respect from
strangers and the press that badly that
it's worth everything to them and so
it's just an astounding story of like
the lifestyle that you choose to live
and the goals that you tend to have like
he wanted this goal more than anyone
else and when he couldn't have it he
took his own life there's a quote from
Nasim talb I'm gonna butcher it but it's
like how interesting it is that more
people commit suicide from Financial
loss than from medical diagnosis he said
it more eloquently but that's roughly
what he said and it's true like losing
your status or your your your internal
dignity however you want to Define it is
more disturbing to people and more
damaging to people than getting a
terminal cancer diagnosis for a lot of
these people so it's just an astounding
story of someone making this crazy
decision the decision to deceive people
and the decision to take his own life
for reasons that just kind of make you
shake your head so I'm gonna I'm gonna
act as a stand in for the audience which
is also acting as a stand in for myself
so people listening to you describe
these various books might think to
themselves for [__] sake Morgan these
are some really hardcore dark books that
you read they don't sound very
reassuring now I understand that it
gives you perspective on how your life
could have gone differently probably
leads to perhaps
valuing your life being grateful for
things that you could take for granted
but let me ask you are there any books
that you have reread or really love that
are more upbeat but still decently high
on the cryome meter for yourself we like
oh God that book just makes me feel so
good I shed a tear a book that doesn't
involve math deaths and destruction is
that what you're saying yeah exactly
right burning to death or committing
suicide at se right fair point I have
one next to me that I'll
give this book it's called the tow of
Charlie
Munger Charlie Munger is one of the most
quoted people ever and this book does a
better job than I've ever seen at
distilling his his best wisdom in a way
that half of the quotes as even as AER
fanatic I had never seen before and
they're just laid out in a very succinct
way that this book is like if you're if
you're an investing fan or a Charlie
Munger fan you should read read this
book once a year it's very easy because
it's basically a book of quotes but I
think Munger is like I I think he's nine
out of 10 on wisdom and he's 10 out of
10 on succinctness and like like saying
something in ay way and you put those
two things together and it's like he's a
really powerful person and and nobody
Burns to death in the book so that's the
upside yeah yeah also what I appreciate
about Charlie
which I think goes hand inand with his
succinctness is he gives zero [__]
which is so fun especially when he's on
live TV talking to somebody at like CNBC
and he's like R [__] it's Bull and
they're like ah Charlie H they can't
rain them in it's so fun oh yeah I've
talked about like some people have [__]
you money Charlie has [__] you
intelligence where at least at least in
his own mind he's like I'm smarter than
you I'm going to tell you how it is and
I don't care what you think about it he
has actually talked about that that's
one of his worst traits no [__] I didn't
know that he would not recommend other
people have that I actually don't think
it's [__] you money I think he had that
trait when he was 13 oh no I don't think
it's [__] you money he just gives zero
[__] but I think it's his preset to
really beat over the head this word that
I keep using rubs a lot of people the
wrong way and I think it also can lead
to even though I'm a massive fan I'm not
just going to say he's the perfect
person because I think that shut up and
let me tell you how it is mentality can
lead to a sense of egotism that makes
you blind to a lot of how the world
works and there are I don't know if I
can think of one off the top of my head
but there have been a number of this is
why I say he's nine out of 10 on wisdom
not 10 out of 10 there are some Charlie
Monger quotes where it's like I think
you believe that because you're a
90-year-old billionaire I actually don't
think that's how the world works for
most people you know I think Buffett is
much more open to how the world Works
versus the world in which he's
experienced fascinating all right might
dig into that separately another time so
let's talk about same as ever how has
writing this book thinking about the
content developing your own thinking
around these
lines informed how you make decisions
if that's a good question feel free to
rephrase it if there's a better way to
put it but how is this informed how you
operate in the world how you make
decisions how you react emotionally to
things however you want to answer that I
think I've always been as an investor
let's focus on that of the view I
mentioned this earlier that no one has
any idea what the future is going to
hold but if you can have the right
behaviors then it doesn't matter
whatever the future throws at you you're
you're going to be okay if you have a
level ahead and a proper asset
allocation for you to absorb all the
surprises so I've never been the kind of
person who's like let's predict what the
stock market's going to do in the next
year let's predict the next recession
I've always just been the like hey if I
can manage my asset allocation and my
mindset so that I can absorb anything
that might happened that's the best we
can do and not only is it the best you
can do if you can actually do that it's
it's really good and so that's what I
try to do with a lot of these topics
that are repeating in life I think a lot
of it can be summarized is viewing life
from 30,000 ft is not only the best that
we can do it's actually a really good
spot to view how the world works and for
so many topics I would say look if you
have cancer you want a doctor who
understands the very fine minute details
of that if you're talking about
investing or philosophy or politics you
you want to stay at 30,000 feet that's
as good as you're going to get and so a
lot of this is just like understanding
the behaviors that are very Broad and
macro rather than fooling yourself into
thinking that you can understand the
finer details of what's going on around
you who's this book for if you want to
build on that what is the audience for
this book what should they hope to come
away from the book Having learned or
absorbed the answer to that will and did
make every publisher shake their head
because they don't like it but it's the
truth for all of my writing the answer
is that the book is for me I wrote it
for me I wrote psychology of money for
me I wrote my all my blog posts for me I
call it selfish writing an audience of
one the reason I do that is not because
I want to think of myself as
self-centered the reason I do it is
because I think you do your best work if
you are being introspective about
yourself and quote unquote knowing your
audience that slips into pandering very
quickly and pandering is the worst
writing not only is it the worst like
content it's the worst writing styles to
Pander to your audience and so I wrote
this book answering questions that I
have about myself and I wrote it in a
style that is interesting to me and I
tell stories that I think are
interesting the probably a lot of death
and destruction because as you can tell
kind of what I gravitate towards look in
most of the world I want to think of
myself as a selfless person except for
writing and then it's like it's just me
and the keyboard and nobody else and I
think that served me really well as a
writer just to stick with an audience of
one for myself now I hope and I think
that I can take a leap of faith that if
I have these questions about myself
other people probably have it about
themselves not everybody you're never
going to please everybody but that's the
leap of faith that I took with
psychology and money it's like those
topics were really interesting to me and
I bet they're interesting to you too so
that's that's what I say now I hope at
the end of both books psychology of
money and same as ever you become more
introspective about what you want out of
life you start answering questions that
you didn't have before about life and
the things in the world that confuse you
and cause you angst in investing in
money in politics in global Affairs
whatever it might be you have a greater
sense of equinity around them not
because you have a new answer but
because you come accepting that there
are some things we can't answer and the
best things that we can do is just
understand the broader behaviors that
guide how people react to these topics
getting on the same page as elanar
Roosevelt trying to trying
to Morgan always enjoy our conversations
is there anything else that you would
like to add anything else you'd like to
mention whether it's a story maybe a
request of the audience anything you'd
like to draw attention to anything you'd
like to say at all before we wind to a
close here the only thing that comes to
mind after having done this twice with
you now Tim is that most conversations
in life I'm exhausted after 20 minutes
and I could go for three hours with you
and keep doing it all day so it's such
an honor to do this and I really admire
your skill as an interviewer it makes
these things so much fun here's what I
would say too as I think about what we
just did here I think half of what I
just said I had never said before on
another podcast and a quarter of it had
never even crossed my mind before which
is a testament to the questions that you
ask so thank you for doing this oh
thanks Morgan I really appreciate you
saying
that fun for me also super fun so that's
I think uh a testament to your ability
to Jazz improv in the way that you did
in this conversation people can find you
online at Morgan household. comom
Twitter Morgan household IG that's
Instagram for you folks of my
vintage the gram at Morgan housel and
the book is same as ever a guide to what
never changes which people can find at
fine book sellers worldwide
and Morgan thank you so much again
really appreciate all the time and to
people listening we will have links to
everything in the show notes as per
usual at tim. blogpad just search Morgan
and this and Morgan's first episode will
pop right up until next time be just a
bit Kinder than is necessary to others
and to yourself and as always thank you
for tuning
in